Yeah,
so I was reviewing a book by a guy named
Mark Mcdonald who teaches at Ucla and
um,
which I think is a terrific book called
the program era.
And the argument of the book is that
American fiction since 1945,
1950,
has been highly influenced by the fact
that so many novelists and so many
people who teach novelists have gone
through writing programs,
um,
and it's not a take down in any way.
His book,
his book basically says that writing
programs provide a certain environment
where a particular kind of fiction gets
produced and these kinds of fiction are
very interesting.
They're often very experimental.
They take fiction of directions that
otherwise it wouldn't go.
It doesn't mean that everything's being
dumbed down or cookie cuttered.
Um,
and I thought that was very provocative
and he gave some pretty good readings of
contemporary fiction to back up his
claim about it.
So I would tend to agree with him.
I mean,
it's,
it is different.
It's a fact of life since 1950 or so,
that wasn't true before that,
um,
writers had different ways of organizing
themselves and different sort of social
groupings in which to perform their
work.
But the fact that many of them go
through the university now,
it does effect what they write but
doesn't mean they write it.
What they're writing is an interesting.
I've,
as I said in that piece,
I myself was a creative writing major in
college and I look back on those
experiences with great fondness and I
think they were very good for me too.
So I think it's a totally appropriate
thing to have inside the academy.
I wish I could say it made it better,
but um,
it certainly gave me lots of models to
bounce off of and learn from.
And then part of it is just that I wrote
poetry and you know,
not that many people are into
contemporary poetry,
but if you can hang out with the people
who are in your college,
it's really a wonderful thing to share.
Um,
and I really valued that a lot,
so I'm glad I had the opportunity to do
it.
And I think it's good thing to good
opportunity for students to have.